okay
I just finished the last mercenary
Mission and I got a double s on it and
there was
I'm sweaty and I'm
[Music]
standby
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay it wasn't intentionally that the
first thing I was gonna do was gonna wow
so incredible power
this so the perspective oh yeah they
gotta be up on the top shelf lady
lipstick what does that even mean
what does it do what is that all that
does
is that all that does
it's not a weapon it's just of course
you have to like why wouldn't you oh
it's gone and oh okay wow
um hi what's up naturally naturally what
ah okay slamtastic power and thrill are
crazy
when an ornate vanity hits three or more
enemies the cool down time to rethrow
the vanity is greatly reduced thrill
keeper increases the time Thrill is
active for makes her look fantastic and
kills her a thrill boots
well you know
yep I I can't disagree with that one oh
you threat your weapon
your
weapons
oh this is so worth it I don't care
about that God yes
let's get the cool down down as far as
possible on that God this is incredible
I don't even know what thrill means what
would thrill means oh my God good deal
if I say so myself you can say whatever
it is you want to say
well that hardly means anything God this
is this is all I've
ever wanted
oh man this was so I mean it was fun
don't get me wrong it was fun I mean I'm
not complaining about anything
yes hello
hello
come on where's my vanity hey God it's
hard to get to you because you're so
you're so small no wonder she was having
trouble fighting Ethan she couldn't even
see
foreign
take a vanity I don't know where I got
that
[Music]
oh my God okay
Control Plus all whoa
it's got daughters on demand
take a vanity
how about some bugs oh yeah
this is
incredible I mean just astonishing
take some of that how about a vanity for
you
God is everything I could have ever
dreamed of ever
oh the only thing I'd say is that I need
to I need to upgrade the claws because
the clock
[Music]
s aren't doing as much damage as I would
like
oh my combo I lost it God I was right
there all right what other abilities can
I have ladies Scissorhands slicing
attacks okay speed increase I think
speed honestly like as I'm there we go
now that's the Menace that I know of you
know if uh Lady D would add a little
more speed when fighting Ethan Winters
let's use you
oh my God I love it so much oh that's
incredible
oh man okay so everything's close-ups
might as well do that God this is the
most wonderful day I'm I'm so happy
and you do take a lot to kill this is
the harder mode by the way I I didn't
know if that was very clear
okay so it's best to combo them right
okay so you do want to combo them left
and right right okay so enough of that
take a vanity
laughs
oh I'm dead no no the power all right
it's fine I'm getting used to it you're
getting used to it hold on everybody
calm down everybody calm down
I may have blown all of my money on
lipstick and maybe that wasn't the best
idea maybe I was only just learning how
to do what it is I need to do
what
it's all good
now I got more powerful Claws and
everything's gonna be fine let's try
this again all right let's do this
oh who's hitting me
okay this is actually great because
there's strategy involved
oh yes
oh yes
God it's incredible all right daughter
go why is it not
cut them
you are
I was just wondering how far I could
throw it objective complete but I need
to kill everything to get the right
bonuses
what are you doing sleeping on the job
I've never been happier
oh I'm so happy you don't understand
I've looked forward to this for so long
I can't even explain just how truly
happy I am
there we go now I'm getting the hang of
it
oh my God okay so charge attack will
really do a lot oh man
holy crap
not dead yet huh
oh man
oh you have no chance
oh wait Cassandra that is a different
daughter so it's like I alternate him
[Applause]
oh man this is incredible
speed okay
one more enemy
[Laughter]
oh man oh there you are
and there you aren't
well they're all dead now
all right
God
this is ah yes and all I'm doing is
picking up money there's no ammo to pick
up so it's like all money all the time
oh the vanity of course more vanity I
don't know what the thrill does yet I'm
not quite uh versed on everything
mechanically in this game just yet but
it's got to be something to do with
increasing damage and allowing you to do
the things that like the other abilities
or something like that
who keeps shooting me with arrows
stop okay
oh come on
all these tiny tiny creatures and now I
get lady D's plight it's hard to hit
things that are tiny
my thrill is low
yeah
okay there's the thrill that's what I'm
looking for
just a little bit of the thrill
that's all
oh hell yeah
excuse me all right let's get the thrill
up
somehow this does indeed get the thrill
up vanity
Bella I don't even remember Bayla
oh God sliced to rhythms
to rhythms I say
oh man
oh close combat attacks of course
man sometimes the damage is just like
incredible take this ah damn it how am I
gonna get you I can't even
bugs
where's my daughter's
daughters hey daughters I'm getting oh
my God it's too I'm Too Tall how is that
even possible how can I be too tall it's
just all I have is my vanity
yeah
oh wow all right so I can get it
Daniela
all right I'm missing some enemies but
honestly I don't oh hello
get down here
you annoying pesky little runts how
could you be so small
and it really goes to your head real
quick don't it I mean I get it yeah I
get it you know I think we all get it I
think everybody gets it like there's
nothing not to get we all get it we get
it I get it you get it we all get it I
probably should have increased this the
bugs are more useful than I thought they
would be
um just because get keeping the thrill
up so the the tactic is to get in there
get your thrill up by applying lipstick
I'm guessing let me get this lipstick on
here excuse me
all right let's see here
and then uh sure
yes there we are oh what are you doing
up there
[Applause]
I can't even get under these things I
can't even go in the buildings anymore
can I how do I get up there is there a
Crouch button oh there is a crush button
come on oh I can't throw when I'm
crouching no I can I can
oh man oh yes please the time
like it's got to be terrifying to see
Lady demetresco
like barreling down at you it's Gotta Be
terrifying well terrifying to some
probably
well I was going for the barrel there
oh you're so tiny
oh you're D oh
well let me just uh you
excuse me I just need a drink in the
middle of this fight
come here you
oh come on oh no not like this come on
not not here at the last stage
there we go
that's what I'm talking about
I'm gonna I vow from this moment on that
I will never stop practicing this game
until I am number one lady Dominic class
commercials mercenaries extra Resident
Evil 8 Village champion of the world
right now it may seem rudimentary but
this is what I will pledge my life to uh
there's one missing isn't this one like
a crow oh no hello who's a Bella did you
get it oh
Bella
oh hello who's there where are you
hello
hello
oh there you are well excuse me one
second hold on
okay this is a little much let me just
hold on a second here you and uh
perfect
I don't know what that means what does
that mean do more damage to enemies
we're being swarmed by oh you get oh my
God if you play dimitrescue more you get
better abilities two-handed slice
attacks what do you mean what do you
mean
too handy excuse me what sorry guys I
just have to I must have missed
something apparently two-handed slice
attacks oh I didn't know that that was a
thing I I f'd up at least practice
oh
if you push both buttons
haha
impressed are you impressed all right I
just got to test out the double-handed
attack says I just got to do that you
know
man this place is Tiny
oh it's you all right I don't have
necessarily what I need to break you
down just yet
there's like landmine no I can't even
use landmines can I
there's just a lipstick
oh ow
oh
oh now
we're starting to really feel this out
uh is there an enemy so I can keep my
combo up there's one
well all right there goes the car oh my
God just go I'm just not used to this
bulk oh yeah when you got this much uh
to haul around it really does
start to hamper you bro I'm missing one
enemy I'll never find it
oh well I guess I'll just have to play
this level over again
oh what a shame I didn't get that
completion bonus my score is way lower
than it should be but my last that is
just the way it is
ah oh my camera died
look so you just put a picture of lady
that's really all it should be anyway I
don't know when that died but it
couldn't have been that long ago so uh
that's the only thing fitting that's
just what it is right now
this is I have no commentary because I
am so focused on the intense gameplay
that you see before you
Nothing Else Matters then uh the utmost
Victory uh that will be guaranteed but
only if I
uh really focus on everything I guess I
could try to put my camera back on but I
don't think I could possibly hold on
I've got oh so many things to worry
about
[Applause]
where are you you tiny man thing
[Music]
yes
ah so the bugs can do that I see I see
oh before I go in there let me do my
ability here
can't lose out on an ability
I
oh those must be a bill okay those are
upgrades that uh that appear only if you
get them from the upgrade thing oh there
I am
I back
I'm back okay good man this I just think
I have a permanent smile on my face and
I I I you know I there's nothing it's
just such a good game the game is so
good and that you can't even follow me
for Santa you can't even like well I'm
just saying that I'm being exaggerated
it's not the game's so good I just got a
permanent smile on my face game of the
year Game of the Year Game of the Year
Game of the Year easy easy easy
no no doubt No Doubt
daughter daughter
you shouldn't be fighting me daughter I
I feel like this is this is uh it's not
okay you know
I feel like uh you deserve that and
maybe you just forgot for a moment who
who I was and I I get it I get it I get
it the bloodlust and all that but um
and uh I won't be nice next time
uh I don't know what you're talking
about I hate you if you're gonna try to
attack me
I hate that you think you can win
because that's pretty pathetic
uh daughter are you on my side or are
you gonna just stand there and be an
idiot well all right you pick uh your
loyalty and I'll I'll guess I'll be
waiting
there we go all dead
ah if only there were some more but alas
ah
oh what the hell has that how long has
that been there God why was that there
why did that oh whatever I have no idea
God this is such a a good episode you
can feel it right you can feel it just
like oh this is like the most quality
probably that I've ever had I think that
I've ever had that I've ever had thank
you for allowing me to get to this point
in my career where I can make the
absolute best uh episode Bar None
without question uh and this is just
incredible
oh right the doll well this is gonna
suck for you
he didn't do as much as I thought it
would go back here
drizzle
hey you get back here
you get back here I'll throw a vanity at
you you better watch yourself
it's like the cackle on the tiniest
little hits yeah
I think the doll is right there man you
really don't want to get caught do you
vanity ah damn it
can I hit you from here
there we go
[Music]
how about this
my God nothing stands a chance
[Applause]
vanity
I am quickly becoming it's almost like I
was meant to be I am quickly becoming
the greatest I think I missed the birds
so I don't think I'm gonna be able to
get those the all kill bonus but
whatever good enough
I
just was always meant to be lady dometre
[Laughter]
I was Destiny it's Destiny that's just
what it is so thank you everybody so
much for watching I think this just
proves that there's just something about
me and
this always just meant to be thank you
I'm Gonna Keep playing
and as always I will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
[Music]